is this true I just have to ask you just  one question  and this happens to a lot of your  position true oh really it is true  murder ya know you recently tweeted that  you failed a Breaking Bad fan quiz yeah  I did and and that's and apparently  according to the quiz that's how many  questions is it like 20 questions many  questions and they say that if you miss  five you can't even consider yourself a  Breaking Bad fan at all I think I got  three right you guys yeah and you're the  star of Breaking Bad yeah how did you  how did that happen  embarrassingly so I you know this is for  real fan fans who say I've watched  Breaking Bad four times all the way  through or safe I've seen every episode  once yeah and the first episode a couple  times so I haven't studied it I know you  study my work oh I'm totally into you  right now Mars candy bar yeah but he  wants to take a train ride  you  you